Spider webs may seem flimsy,
but their silk is actually five times stronger than steel—
and researchers have started to figure out why.
The new insights came from using an atomic
force microscope to look closely at the silk
of the venomous brown recluse spider.
At this minute level, each strand of silk,
which is a thousand times thinner than a strand
of human hair, is composed of even smaller
nanostrands— just two millionths of a centimeter in diameter.
The shape of the silk, a flat ribbon, allowed
them to construct the most detailed structural
model of spider silk to date.
The brown recluse spiders' unique looping technique
further strengthens the webbing of this silk.
The idea that nanofibers make up spider silk
has been proposed before, but until now there
was no evidence to suggest that nanostrands
comprise the entire makeup of a silk fiber.
Researchers hope their work will help us unreel
one of the toughest materials of the natural world.